[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit die
serien ihnen allem guten abend zu einem
knackigen halbzeit update der
wichtigsten geschehnisse hier ist der
überblick
40 länder an einem tisch in ramstein
diskutiert eine internationale allianz
was der ukraine militärisch helfen
könnte
jetzt also doch die bundesregierung
wechselt den kursen ist bereit zur
lieferung schwerer waffen
im namen der vereinten nationen antonio
guterres dringt in moskau auf frieden
und diplomatie
ja seit heute ist klar deutschland
liefert der ukraine die von vielen
seiten immer wieder geforderten schweren
waffen flugabwehr panzer die ankündigung
dazu erfolgte an prominenter stelle und
zwar in ramstein bei einer
internationalen konferenz zu der die usa
einlud und wo heute über die
langfristige unterstützung für die
ukraine beraten wurde bei dem treffen am
größten us luftwaffenstützpunkt
außerhalb der usa waren vertreter aus
rund 40 ländern dabei rammstein liegt
bei kaiserslautern und ist der
wichtigste flughafen der us streitkräfte
in europa benjamin daniel fasst zusammen
die us-airbase ramstein seit rund 70
jahren eine der wichtigsten us
militärbasen weltweit in den offiziers
club durften heute ausnahmsweise auch
eine ganze menge zivilisten und jeder
der hierher eingeladen hat gab vor knapp
zwei stunden seine pressekonferenz
wir haben keine zeit zu verlieren die
gespräche heute haben verdeutlicht dass
die nächsten wochen entscheidend sein
werden wir müssen uns der dynamik des
krieges anpassen und ich weiß dass alle
teilnehmer heute entschiedener denn je
abreisen die ukraine in ihrem kampf
gegen die russische aggression zu
unterstützen
um so mehr der westen tut desto lauter
die warnung aus moskau vor einer
nuklearen eskalation
ich will diese gefahren nicht künstlich
überhöhen es gibt viele die genau das
versuche die gefahr ist ernst sie ist
real und man darf sie nicht
unterschätzen und
trotzdem nun eine weitere kehrtwende der
bundesregierung nach langem hin und her
ist plötzlich möglich was bis heute
ausgeschlossen wurde wir haben die
entscheidung getroffen dass es jetzt
wichtig ist in bezug auf die flugabwehr
zu unterstützen das kann mit dem der
part geleistet werden und das steht auch
genau auf der liste dessen was die
ukraine braucht und so geht das ringen
weiter um den besten weg in und aus der
krise und moskau hört ganz genau zu
also nach wochenlangem hin und her heute
das deutsche bekenntnis zur lieferung
von flugabwehrraketen
auch die union die die bundesregierung
in dieser angelegenheit vor sich
hertreibt begrüßt die ankündigung und
gut möglich dass ampel und union in der
frage der waffenlieferungen jetzt
schneller zueinander finden seit zehn
jahren ausgemustert der gepard panzer
hier in einem bundeswehr video der
gepard war ein hoch mobiler
flugabwehrkanonen panzer des heeres
seine hauptaufgabe der schutz vor tief
fliegenden flugzeugen und
kampfhubschraubern
jetzt sein comeback mit der nachricht
heute um 9 uhr 23 ampel fraktionen
fordern schwere waffen für die ukraine
in einem ersten schritt sollen 50 alte
keeper panther durch einen münchner
waffen hersteller wieder aufbereitet und
in die ukraine geschickt werden ein
paradigmenwechsel getrieben von grünen
und fdp nämlich dass wir als deutschland
bereit sind schwere waffen in die
ukraine zu liefern das ist ein ganz
wichtiges politisches signal
dabei werden im neuen ampel antrag
direkte waffenlieferungen gar nicht
erwähnt hier wird lediglich versprochen
auch die lieferung auf schwere waffen
und komplexe systeme etwa im rahmen des
ringtausch es zu erweitern für die spd
war der weg am weitesten aber auch
fraktionschef mützenich ist nun dafür
ich finde das eben auch diese
entscheidung der bundesregierung
zusammen mit den partnern die getroffen
worden sind verantwortbar sind die union
signalisiert zustimmung im bundestag sie
hatte in ihrem antrag sehr viel
konkreter waffenlieferungen gefordert
hier sollte deutschland nicht der
bremser bleiben sondern wir wollen dass
deutschland das tut was andere in der
europäischen union und auch andere in
der nato für richtig halten neben dem
gepard gibt es weitere angebote aus der
rüstungsindustrie die bundesregierung
bereits prüft
zur einordnung theo koll in berlin die
union hat die ampel und den kanzler in
der frage schwerer waffenlieferungen ja
unter druck gesetzt wie sieht's jetzt
aus
vor allem hat sich die ampel selbst
unter druck gesetzt bei allem willen der
koalitionsspitzen nicht in eine
regierungskrise zu steht dann war doch
zunehmend erkennbar dass das klare
meinungsunterschiede gibt was die
ausgerufene zeitenwende eigentlich
bedeutet und just die partei des
kanzlers will am wenigsten wänden mit
dem ergebnis des olaf scholz obwohl er
ja die richtlinien der politik
vorzugeben hat in all den fragen wie der
ukraine zu helfen ist wie ein
getriebener erscheint der die eigenen
positionen erst nach langem zögern
verändert man kann und muster bei dem
kanzler zugute halten dass er
insbesondere bei der frage der schweren
waffen immer auch sein amt seit also das
wohl des deutschen volkes im blick hatte
aber er war es der die zeitenwende
ausgerufen hat und damit offensichtlich
die messlatte höher gelegt hat als er
selbst und oder teile seiner partei
bereits sind zu springen und dadurch
wirkt sein viel mehr als früher zu tun
über lange strecken eben noch immer als
zu wenig danke für die analyse theo koll
nach berlin auch auf diplomatischer
ebene gibt es bewegung der
uno-generalsekretär ist heute in moskau
am abend kamen bot er im kreml mit
präsident putin zusammen zuvor hatte er
sich schon mit außenminister lavrov
getroffen und eine sofortige waffenruhe
gefordert
die kämpfe gehen derweil weiter russland
hat nach ukrainischen angaben innerhalb
eines tages 35 luftangriffe auf das
stahlwerk us aufs tal in mario pohl
geflogen auch in der moldauischen
konflikt region transnistrien die an die
ukraine grenzt hat es mehrere
explosionen gegeben
ausspähen und abhören von wohnungen
online-durchsuchungen ortung per handy
seit 2016 hat bayerns verfassungsschutz
ziemlich weit reichende befugnisse
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat jetzt
entschieden dies verstößt teilweise
gegen grundrechte bayern kündigte an das
gesetz entsprechend den vorgaben
anzupassen und das urteil dürfte auch
auswirkungen auf andere länder und den
bund haben
genau 20 jahre ist es her dass ein
junger mann in erfurt an seiner
ehemaligen schule zahlreiche menschen
tötete
heute glockenschläge um eine minute nach
elf dem zeitpunkt als das massaker
begann am gutenberg-gymnasium verharrten
hunderte unter ihnen thüringens
ministerpräsident ramelow in stillem
gedenken an die opfer der 19 jährige ex
schüler erschoss damals 16 menschen und
sich selbst
ja das war es vom 19 uhr team
verteidigungsministerin lamprecht ab 21
uhr 45 im heute-journal interview mit
christian sievers und hier geht es
gleich nach dem wetter mit dem fußball
benefizspiel zur unterstützung der
ukraine weiter schön abend schönen dunk
und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter heute gab es
schauer und gewitter mit einem tief was
sich nun allmählich verlagert in der
nacht gibt es aber noch regen richtung
bayern sonst klart es verbreitet auf und
die temperaturen sinken ordentlich ab
minus ein grad richtung ostsee 0 grad im
nordwesten und 6 grad im süden es wird
also eine kalte nacht morgen im
tagesverlauf viel sonnenschein nach
norden und westen im südosten noch
letzte schauer das lässt allmählich nach
und das bei höchsten temperaturen von 16
bis 18 grad in den östlichen
landesteilen 18 grad im
rhein-main-gebiet und 19 grad am
oberrhein und damit eine schöne art